[Music]
so you know what i found out today that
apparently rob schneider has beef with
or actually no
patent oswald has beef with rob
schneider how do you beef with rob i
don't [ __ ] know he doesn't do
anything to anybody
yeah it's like some people that are just
so nice that you know if somebody's got
a problem with them they have some kind
of personality disorder it's like if
somebody legitimately hated frozen asian
i'd be like what
why
i mean we kayfabe hate them but
yeah shoot hate [ __ ] frozen asian why
what did he do or pessi's another one
you'd go you must have a [ __ ] weird
issue you hate pezzi virgi i get
no oh absolutely virginia i get it i get
it so here's here's another clip here
when rob schneider was on bill maher
after the after here i got to go do a
show on melrose with two people the
[ __ ] i know hate me you know pat and
oswald and this other comedian but they
wrote a book and both the books they
[ __ ] on me and it's like you know what
who i hate is not those guys as much as
the friends who tell you did you read
that in the book you know that friend
who tells you
okay wait a second what is the show and
why do you have to do this i don't know
because adam carol you reached out to me
adam carl reached out we do this gig for
me it's going to be on melrose and i
said yeah you're coming on mill rose
it's at the improv just come to a set
and i said absolutely i'll figure it out
i can't make me understand
i understand who adam corolla is i know
where melrose is
bill maher drunk is is is a different
vibe bill maher's always high
yeah like bill maher is usually not this
[ __ ] but he's like wait wait
wait
the improv it looks like there are a
couple bottles in from one rose improv
i'm kind of looking at the table wait a
minute wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait they're drinking look at that
look at the bottles hang on a second
adam corolla yes
improv
melrose yes
pat knoxville
you're just saying names you're saying
comedians that's what he's doing
it's hard to wrap my head around rob
schneider doing a set
at the improv right where every comic
goes to every la comet goes there whoa
i'm trying to wrap my head around this
rob that's pretty [ __ ] hard by the
way you know the funny part isn't rob
goes
i i you were there
you came up after me whoa whoa whoa whoa
you're blowing my mind man
you can slow down
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] never do press anymore because i
don't give a [ __ ] why are you burying
the lead about plugging something you're
on something that people are going to
hear
you're like trying to like i'm trying to
hide it all right okay i got a movie
coming out yeah so anyway i'm doing this
so i have nothing coming out
he called me up and he did what is the
name of the movie daddy daughter trip
okay i also love the there's another
reason i love rob schneider he's going
on these shows and bill maher's like but
you're here plug your thing and he's
like i don't care like i don't really
care and you're like bro this is awesome
you know where is this it's the only
move my wife won't let my kids see where
is this movie on
it's going to be just playing in arizona
to start oh it's a theater movie it's a
theater okay yeah and then it's going to
go out otherwise so you're you're doing
this thing on melrose to plug it well
i'm i'm going i went on adam today okay
adam crowell's show with them okay and
then i'm on i'm gonna come into yours
and i'm doing some promotion to promote
the movie coming up oh and so he said
you come down to a set i didn't know
it's gonna be like pat and oswald
sarah silverman and i love sarah but
like i just it was just that right
you're with some super woke
comedians yes
and i don't need that [ __ ] sweetheart i
do
what's going on
with bill maher lately man like
i understand look and look again i'll
never forgive him because he helped
create this
but there's some people that you think
do they really mean it i do actually
believe he'll never admit it i think he
regrets some of this some of the i do
believe he regrets some of the [ __ ] he
did
but
i honestly think he's had it too right
every video we've seen lately because
remember we saw
just doing this show
we saw his transition
from him going from like
you know he hit the right really hard
and maybe a little bit the left then he
started going like 50 50 and now it's
like this right he still makes fun of
trump and all that stuff but like all
his monologues now are like what the
[ __ ] are we doing seriously he's he's
kind of going through what we went
through when trump became president yeah
and started [ __ ] things up yeah good
point and then like all these different
patriot prayer types started [ __ ]
things up and it was like yo if we don't
right this ship we're gonna lose that's
why i think it's he still wants the left
to win he's just mad now because they're
being so [ __ ] [ __ ] they're gonna
lose they're gonna throw the game
but some pilate goes no bill maher is
the enemy i didn't say he was a friendly
i literally started this by saying i
won't forgive him for doing this i'm
just observing like like exactly what
merce just said like
are you seeing not that it makes it okay
not that they're your friends but are
you are you seeing some of them start to
go [ __ ] and look it's maybe even for
selfish reasons i think for the most
part it's selfish reasons because now
it's affecting them right now it's
affecting the kind of jokes bill maher
could tell you know well yeah it's it's
it's fine when all this shit's happening
in all these other places but when it
comes to your backyard all of a sudden
you're like new rule okay black people
should get arrested for breaking into my
car
by the way luffy
luffa reagan on the chat goes if word
still had meanings meaning i would be a
liberal that's a good point i guess you
know
i i don't know so i don't think that's
the real lou ferrigno if i'm being
honest he might i mean i don't know
you're right he's deaf
close caption i guess
is he deaf yeah legally deaf yeah
you think you just talk like that could
do with stupid
yeah don't either oh he's deaf i love
sarah i don't know pat not well but
patton and i
you mean patton the guy that apologized
for hugging dave chappelle
that guy
the patton oswalt that said i'm so sorry
dave chappelle was my friend trans
people that guy
he and that came after me to apologize
for taking a picture with a black man
which is fun it's just twisted around
which is so [ __ ] funny yeah
once yeah and then i saw him at a dinner
we patched it up it was nice he was he
had a he [ __ ] on me in his book yeah he
[ __ ] on me once on twitter but like at
this yeah and it's like the thing about
it is like he shouldn't but well
he should stop like so many of the
people in show business
stop being indoctrinated you know what
there's there's liberalism and then a
lot of you are just [ __ ]
indoctrinated yes and like what a [ __ ]
this guy is let me say about pat and
oswald yes ah i thought he was gonna be
nice but now bill can i give bill credit
on this end
bill is very good interviewer right you
got to give him that even he's a piece
of [ __ ] he's a leftist shill
that was pretty pretty pro move there
here's the thing that bothers me talk
about whatever you want and like i get
it and he's brilliant blah blah blah but
he is he brilliant or is he a guy who's
just an extra in every marvel movie now
he was brilliant yeah very funny guy at
one point turn your son up a little bit
did you message your son by any chance
no okay
no it might not be again you're good
you're good there it's probably zoom you
know how that [ __ ] is he [ __ ] took a
picture with dave chappelle and [ __ ]
okay he's bringing it up
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] i've never
apologized for a [ __ ] joke in my life
and believe me when they did the the uh
the netflix special i did the last thing
they cut [ __ ] so they got 15 minutes
out 15 wait wait that's about normal
15 minutes is about what gets trimmed at
an hour respect right give or take
i don't think that's depending on how
long you went yeah i'm sure that's true
wait how is this a special wasn't 25
minutes and five takes
big of a game
you have a netflix special okay yeah
they cut my fajita joke it was [ __ ]
phenomenal they said that apparently
there was this other guy named brendan
schaub who was doing it we got a cease
and desist from
some called thick boy
whatever that is no it would still be
bent pixels
it came out two years ago during that
okay well okay i probably saw it but two
weeks ago two years ago but i'm saying
though they cut the stuff out you know
and it's that's right i remember the
special there was a big issue because it
it it was it came it was came on right
after nick schwartzen's
fajitas special so stupid it's such a
stupid image
[Laughter]
it's childish is what it is
but god bless them but they got their
thing but like there's some stuff that i
wish they wouldn't have
the that but that's like well i must say
i'm not bitter you can tell i must say
they didn't do a very good job of
promoting it they didn't because i want
to hang out
with rob schneider and by the way is
bill drunk yes rob schneider's drinking
uh wine bill has whiskey uh next to his
decanter so that's there's your
difference by the way i don't blame him
this studio is the one that's in his
house so [ __ ] get hammered bro
i would have watched it if i knew you
had a special oh thank you i would
totally be there the only reason i
didn't see that is because i never knew
about it well and that's not really on
you well he's hammered bro the way he's
doing the
bill i'm from what i'm learning at least
here bill is one of those
starts loving you when he's hammered
yeah not because there's an angry
hammered guy but then there's like bro
you're my bro bro yeah you're my bro bro
bro bro
well i think that they they just they
have a lot of content they get so big
they just but they push their big guys
yes chappelle but i like i mean you know
the stuff that they cut out was stuff
that chappelle did in his you know
what's the same subject matter i mean oh
he's mad because he had similar i read
something about the similar like trans
jokes
and they cut it out of his special but
they didn't cut it out of chappelle's i
think that's fair you know what i'd be
pissed i'd be pissed
i'm not taking away from chappelle he's
a genius you know he's he's the you know
of that generation the best comedian for
sure
you know he came after us um and really
believe that or do you just have to say
that
yes
do you really believe that you have this
yeah you want to see that let's do that
again russ um and really believe that or
do you just have to say that
yes uh you do i do i mean i'm a huge fan
of his but i also think people just at
some some point people just line up
behind an opinion because it is the
correct opinion time is your double date
he's
probably not wrong with that what bill
just said
he's actually not wrong with that
i'm not doing another show tonight i'm
going to stay here till make sure yeah
what time is your double date with pat
oswalt i don't know um
no first of all he's a funny comic i
don't mean to jitter but i thought
wouldn't either one of us should good
job bill keep [ __ ] god keep giving bill
more credit but he's
good even even drunk this guy's gonna
[ __ ] get him off yeah
the photo thing pissed me off i don't
blame you
when he tweeted about me whatever he was
it pissed me off but what i'm saying is
he's doing the relate with the hymns
you know
to apropos to our discussion about the
country at large yeah when i saw patton
i came to some dinner i remember it was
like a year after i love hearing other
comics [ __ ] i'm pat and also guys i'm so
sorry but this is this i gotta do i need
this it feels so good i don't know slam
this right into my veins [ __ ]
mainline it i hate penn oswald i smoke
pot but when i went to i saw this i went
to a dinner i think al franken was there
sarah was there wow it sounds great and
i didn't know patton was there i could
have been like you know this [ __ ]
he you know
and i think it was something i said
about islam
probably yes
which i'm clear-eyed about and not an
islamophobe yeah and not a racist it's a
religion not a race we won't get into
that but yes it's one of those issues
where the woke are very very benighted
and i'm clear-eyed about it without
being
you know i think you don't want to
attack people like that right beautiful
woman um
i what's her name ayan herself herself
she's a hero she's not embraced by the
liberal intelligence right so much
sam harris tells a great story about a
bunch of people
sorry about that
i disagree with you saying sam harris
does anything well
sam harris is someone who every speech
he tells should be muffled through a
locker because he's a [ __ ] nerd and
he's not as smart as everybody thinks he
is just because you talk like frasier
crane doesn't mean in real life you're
not actually kelsey grammer
white drugs
someone who was brought up in somalia
and was the victim of
genital um
you know genital mutilation mutilation
and lots of other horrible petricidal
unbelievable
that western women pretend that they're
so against
ouch
and then she goes to the then she goes
let's continue she goes to holland the
point is becomes a legislator i
certainly thought he was out of line
with whatever he tweeted about me
and it but instead of like when i was
younger i probably would have been like
oh this i'm not even talking to him yeah
you know because we were always feuding
when we were younger i was like okay you
know maybe he had a bad day or maybe we
can talk this out and maybe his [ __ ]
wife died because of pills that he gave
her maybe that we don't know we don't
know why i don't know we don't know
but we do know is he moved along really
fast yep like hyperspeed yeah his kid
got a new mommy right away real [ __ ]
they didn't even change your sheets on
the bend
oh jesus christ man
sorry that was [ __ ] dark
they didn't even go through the whole
thing of toothpaste that the other wife
was using
[Laughter]
oh no i didn't see he was drinking
[Laughter]
you're right man oh i almost murdered
him
dude i should all right you know like
yeah like pat knoxville did his wife
allegedly literally obviously
i had to swallow that so fast because i
was going to spit it out you know like
in the cartoons
when like the garden hose has like
like a giant [ __ ] thing of water
going in it like that's what it felt
like
and it so like that's what america has
to do like i don't i don't hate you you
said one thing which i really thought
was out of line but you know maybe if i
just engaged you and that's exactly what
happened and i wound up talking to him
about health and he wound up saying
i have emails where i don't have them
but i had them but were like oh you know
you really saved my life
because i'm doing this like i
hipped him onto this like certain kind
of fast you could do and stuff like that
i mean that's what america has to do
right and he's really a i mean he's a
yeah you're right you you you [ __ ]
literally want to lock people up forever
for going to a protest but we need to
just tell each other about fast here's
the problem bill maher still loses it
he's still an la [ __ ] douche bag or a
new york douchebag one of those [ __ ]
douche bags that still thinks like oh
yeah if you're mad at your super famous
friend all you got to do is talk about a
diet
you're right it's so out of time that's
it we're good now america just needs to
talk about their diets more yeah you're
right no that's what it is people don't
have food bill
you [ __ ] idiot see that's where he
always loses me that being said i want
to end this by saying
rob schneider is amazing
okay we will there's we are we will
always love rob schneider here